so after a certain point you've had so
many relationships you put yourself on
sets it's okay that and like honestly
you should have like it it's a sign of
ego if you say I can't put myself on
sale like who are you I don't know I
just I think maybe because my mindset is
always spiritual first like I come from
a very spiritual perspective of things
so I just feel like so if I was to say
I'm damaged okay I can say I'm damaged
but then I'm that's not going to be my
story I don't want that to it will be
your story
I don't want it to be the thing that I'm
like oh I'm damaged so therefore I can't
you know what I mean I don't think you
can't it's just like